[Musik]
auch das zweite spiel der
fußballweltmeisterschaft der frauen hat
das deutsche team in frankreich gewonnen
es war wieder ein arbeitssieg wieder
endete das spiel mit 1 0 und wieder war
es so dass der sieg als glücklich
bezeichnet werden muss und die
spanierinnen dominierten vor allem die
erste halbe stunde derart dass man
richtig angst und bange wurde um das
deutsche team wie so oft scheitern die
spanierin allerdings an ihrer schwäche
im abschluss
und auch an täter in almuth schult die
große gewinnerin des deutschen auftritts
war durch sichere flanken abwehr durch
faust- abwehren die in höchster not
retten durch starkes spiel im
eins-gegen-eins gegen herannahende
gegnerinnen
dadurch hat das deutsche team so langsam
gegen ende der ersten halbzeit wenig an
sicherheit gewonnen und dann natürlich
das große glück gehabt dass mit dem
ersten konsequent zu ende gespielten
angriff das 1 0 fiel
positiv kann bundestrainerin martina
voss tecklenburg
ähnlich wie im ersten spiel zur kenntnis
nehmen dass ihre mannschaft trotz sehr
turbulenter situationen vor dem eigenen
tor den kopf nicht hängen ließ und dass
sie mit erhobenem kopf auch in die
weiteren zweikämpfe gingen negativ ist
natürlich weiterhin zu vermerken dass es
an der sicherheit im spiel mit dem ball
fehlt und dem deutschen team somit die
uhr ab geht martina voss tecklenburg hat
zudem die hoffnung geäußert dass die
mannschaft durch eben diese widrigen
umstände der ersten spiele vielleicht
eine andere entwicklung verlaufe des
turniers sind als andere teams die
relativ leichte einstieg mit hohem
fliegen wie die abhängigen staaten ins
turnier haben
das ist so etwa wieder die philosophie
wir glauben an das deutsche
turniermannschaft phänomen
vielleicht liegt damit nicht ganz falsch
allein die hoffnung sollte es allerdings
nicht bleiben sondern man sollte auch
tatsächlich an den
stellschrauben drehen die bislang nicht
funktionierten
die erste etappe qualifikations
achtelfinale ist geschafft das wartet
aber noch viel arbeit für das deutsche
team
auf dem weiteren weg
[Musik]